[Music]
hello and welcome to marshall matters
with me winston marshall at the
spectator buildings in london today i'm
joined by rosie k and it's a day for
celebration because rosie has just
launched k2 co her new dance company but
the reason behind why she even had to
start a new dance company in the first
place is a little sad perhaps to say the
least
but
rosie's here to tell us all about that
rosie thank you so much for uh joining
me today you're welcome thanks for
inviting me so can you uh before we talk
about the exciting new project you've
got can you tell us about your story why
you've had to start anew
um so i'm a dancer and choreographer um
i've done since i was very very young
and i've been lucky enough to have it as
the sort of meaning of my life really um
i danced professionally for quite a few
years mostly abroad but also in the uk
and then
i almost gave up i kind of went down the
wrong track and i realized that i wanted
to actually be a choreographer i wanted
to make my own work
so in 2004 i returned to the uk
i set up my own dance company radica
dance company and i started to explore
uh the funding uh with the arts council
and making first solo and duet work and
then i built up to sort of large scale
productions
so um
i was we were doing quite well and we
applied to get regular funding
um and i was advised at the time to turn
my company that was limited by share
into a charity
and under english law i had to
voluntarily step down as a director
and i became an employee but but it was
still my name and i was the sole
artistic creator and i earned the money
and you know i i ran the company
basically so i really still felt it was
my company
and i had a board of trustees um
many of whom i'd known for many many
years
um and it was quite a sort of hands-off
approach i just got on making my work
i'd say that my work has
had a political element and i'm
interested in the world we live in and
so at times i'd skirted with
controversial subject
and so when we set up the charity
um i very deliberately you know put into
the charitable objects that um this
company existed for the artistic
creation of rosie k to look at
controversial and taboo subject matters
shining a light on on difficult subjects
so what would be an example of some of
them so a great example would be five
soldiers so um quite a while ago i
suffered a really bad injury on stage
and following the sort of i was told
that i wouldn't dance again and it would
take me about a year to walk again it
was like full need reconstruction i was
told
and following the operation where it
turned out not to be that bad
i dreamt i was on a desert battlefield
and my leg had been blown off
and it made me question ideas about the
body and the soul and the relationship
between the body and the soul so i'd
have done anything to get back on stage
and dance again and
you know
you could i could lose my arms and my
legs but would i still want to dance yes
i would
and i went downstairs and it was the
iraq war at that time and there was a
lot of kind of antipathy about why we
were at war particularly in iraq
and and and that the argument had never
really gone that deeply into it and so i
was looking at the faces of young
soldiers killed in iraq and i wondered
how do you train
the body to prepare for war
and maybe they're a bit more like
dancers than we realize maybe they love
what they do
and so that set me on a long journey i
spent time with an infantry battalion
training with them i spent time at
headley court
looking at the
rehabilitation of injured soldiers
and by that stage the ward moved to
afghanistan and these huge numbers of
soldiers were coming back having
survived multiple complex trauma
when in iraq they wouldn't have survived
so that sort of golden
window of survival had
massively got better in afghanistan but
people were living from injuries that
they wouldn't have lived off several
years previously in war
so i got access to soldiers sort of the
training
the breaking and the putting back
together again of their bodies
at a time when nobody else
was was allowed to actually um so i made
a work about it and when we first heard
it the mod phoned up and tried to get
the shows stopped because it was the
time of the 2010 elections so i was able
to say to the mod well actually it's a
free country this is not um i'm not a
politician and this is a work of art and
i'm allowed to put this on what why
would they have wanted it to be
so it was
at the time and so um the press and
politicians were not allowed to talk
about the war in afghanistan during the
20 during the election there's that
period where you're not allowed to talk
about
the war
well well until i think it was david
cameron got in 2010 so so me just having
a show that was
on the news in the on the radios on the
today program talking about it that they
got worried
they thought you're not allowed to do
that but but i was like yes i am
actually so supposed to a show like that
it changed perceptions not just of the
general public in that it humanized
soldiers but i can say it even changed
perceptions within the army itself who
went from being quite uh resistant and
a bit worried about me to actually
supporting and
you know putting some money towards the
the show touring the past few years so
that's been quite remarkable to work
with the military at that sort of level
through the arts it's been kind of you
know
blows away your stereotypes and
preconceptions on all fronts
you're not scared of controversy
obviously and yet and so
last year if i understand this correctly
you wanted to put on a production of
orlando by virginia woolf
which was
stepping into the trans debate
so i i actually was in in like 10 days
away from premiering
another work romeo and juliet which i'd
set in contemporary birmingham
and i'd worked with
west midlands police
gang former gang members
really intensely with a school in spark
hill
looking at the themes of romeo and
juliet knife crime
child marriage gang gang culture
and then putting this show together so i
had a young cast of nine dancers
uh a lot of whom were very inexperienced
and there was just something funny going
on
in the studio i i put it down to covid
um would you mean funny the mood was
fine the mood was funny i just found
that people weren't as open as normal
and i started to sort of just be first
of all
i was my father was going through the
very
horrible end of life with maternal
cancer so i first put it down to the
fact that i was really quite sensitive
and it was really difficult because i
couldn't see them very often because of
covered restrictions um but then i i
just found that
talking to them they they
they didn't seem very open they didn't
seem as collaborative as i would
normally expect for dancers and um i
wanted to kind of relax them and and
show that i really cared about them you
know what age are these sort of in their
in their uh early to mid twenties okay
so they're sort of starting out yeah
it's a new generation yes yes and and so
you you can't sort of quite tell what
they're thinking was it a sort of mood
of self-censorship were they getting on
with each other or they just finding it
hard to communicate with you yeah i i
couldn't tell because we had such strong
restrictions we weren't even allowed to
eat lunch together we had to sit
down because
yeah so we just sit at a different place
in the studio and you would sort of
snatch one-to-one conversations but um
[Music]
i started to just feel a bit
uncomfortable i i thought some i did
think something was going on looking
back
something was going on um i i noticed it
like in like i'll teach class and if i
gave a correction
i would see eyes rolling and i would be
like well hang on
you know i've talked for for 25 years i
i'm not telling you because i think
you're wrong or or you know because i'm
trying to assert my power i'm telling
you because this is technically really
important and this saves your knees and
this is what you need to do you know
like it's a really technical is that a
problem with authority they had or i
think so yes there's a generational that
generation maybe had a problem being
told what to do by anyone i think so i
think there's an element of that and
there's a real pedagogic tradition in
dance like we we
i would say i'm a quite a democratic
choreographer i invite um you know
people to give me their ideas their
creativity and then i use it but i can
also make works where i'm like this is
the choreography and this is how you do
it and you need to do it in this way
because that's a result i want you know
that's your role as a choreographer as a
director there are times to be really
opening sharing and then there's times
where you have to be like this is how
good you have to be
this was a show
on one of the biggest stages in the uk
there was a lot of pressure on it and
these dancers didn't have experience in
that i do so i was i just didn't feel
like i was being um like they were very
generous i didn't feel they were very
generous to me
and that was quite odd i'm not used to
that i feel like it's a it's a fantastic
place to studio you can you know we're
making it up guys
exactly and they should have been felt
lucky to have the opportunity to work
with you in the first place i imagine
given they had no experience and you've
got an incredible
career behind you to you know for them
to learn from it it was a fantastic show
we had amazing music we were using the
berlioz score we had fantastic
opportunities to do it with a live
orchestra
uh the whole staging the costumes was
fabulous and
you've got to bear in mind most people
were completely unemployed right through
covered
it was a nightmare for freelancers so i
really felt like it was
my duty to try and keep going and offer
people work as much as i possibly could
so in that context you bring up orlando
by virginia woolf as a as a proposition
for a new production
so so so i invited the dancers to my
house they they stayed
till too late
um and and i regret you know not not
listening to something he's a party
it's a big rave there's a big rave
haven't it yourself sort of but it was
still it wasn't crazy because you know
the gardens next to my son's bedroom you
know we weren't being ridiculous um
what what they did was they asked me
what my next show was and i was about
two years into preparation for orlando
and i was just about to put an audition
notice out okay um and i'd already been
having that week a few arguments or
debates
uh about the wording of this
audition notice and and someone
very junior in my company had sort of
reworded it to sort of include
gender euphoria or something like this
and i was like hey hang on i i'm not
sure i'm just looking for a
it's a it's a male aristocrat yeah so
this is the the story by virginia woolf
or orlando so people who haven't read
the book
can you tell us the story
so it's it's a fantastic sort of um
it's virginia woolf playing with um form
and style
and she's having a lot of fun and
there's a lot of humor and we meet this
young slightly wet hero in elizabethan
england
and he wants to become a poet but he's a
dreadful poet but he's desperately
trying to be an artist and so there's
lots of kind of like
discussion around what makes an artist
really an artist even though you may
feel you're an artist if your work is
really dreadful does that mean that
you're an artist or not
and he falls in love and he gets
horribly rejected and then he becomes an
ambassador in morocco and then at that
point where there's a there's a civil
war and he's meant to grab his firearms
he actually sort of runs away and falls
asleep
and when he wakes up
he's a woman that's it
he's a woman no further explanation
then orlando carries on through another
three to three hundred years of history
so so he he she never
ages
um
and the novel changes as we go through
the georgian era and then we go into the
victorian era and then we finally end
where virginia woolf just blasts you
with her sort of 20th century stream of
consciousness bang into the modern age
and so it's 400 years of english history
it's a hero turns into a heroine so it
looks at
how people behave around orlando orlando
when they're a man and when they're a
woman but it also looks at even
inheritance because orlando is a woman
can't inherit the great big country pile
it's our also it's a love letter to vita
sackville west who was her lover and
they had a terribly passionate
relationship
um
but vita was also madly enough with her
country pile that she would never
inherit
um and so there's something in there
also about about a lesbian love affair
about
sort of showing off tavita her prowess
and i just love that because you you can
you can play with costume you can play
with theatricality you can play with
body kind of like how do we know this
person is a man how do we know they're a
woman
i never i i'd been speaking to a couple
of trans friends of mine and an lgbt
group book group
and i just was like i don't know who my
orlando is they just have to be
fantastic
it could be a man could be a woman could
be trans could be i don't know
it's just got to be somebody that can be
convincing
well obviously virginia woolf would
never have had any concept of what a
trans person was and this is a a book of
fantasy in in in a sense
tied in with uh kind of the the history
of reality but
uh in in the context of 2021 last year
a book like that is going to be
interpreted
not quite maybe how virginia woolf had
intended
but but but i felt like this is a this
is a
a feminist writer a great of the 20th
century
i've positioned
a female viewpoint at the center of all
my work since i started making work in
1998.
i'm an artist that has a standing that
can interpret this
in the way i want to
now i'm also someone that sort of um
sadly my brother died so so i grew up um
with steam train posters on my wall with
um being obsessed i thought i was tin
tin for a while uh with being on the
school football team until they kicked
me off despite me being the best striker
and they said well i'm sorry rosie
you're a girl you know i'm someone
that's kind of gone well if i were a boy
what would i do what would i get away
with that's much harder when you're a
woman
and then also being
now an older you know older woman i've
been through enough whether that be
sexual assault sexual harassment i've
even talked about rape in one of my
shows i've been through
abortion i've been through
a really dangerous pregnancy and birth
there are things that have affected me
because of my body and because of my
biology
that i want to talk about
that i think are really vital and
interesting to talk about
um i wasn't an artist
that put me in my body center place
in terms of like the work i made i
wanted to look at the world
but now i'm at the age where i think
well actually i can put myself into my
work as well and i can put my own
opinions into my work and be more open
about that
so you know i'd made this solo adult
female dancer also in 2021 and it
premiered and it and it said being a
woman is not in my head i say that in
the in the solo so in some respects i
felt like i
was starting to kind of like
i knew there was this argument going on
around trans
but i also think it's something that
is a cultural phenomenon and that really
interests me if we're going to redefine
identity and biology i want to be
looking at this this is fascinating
what's going on here
yeah why can't i look at it particularly
if in in your field of choreography
where the body is so integral to the art
form there's a beautiful piece you're a
great prose writer as well a beautiful
piece you wrote for unheard at the end
of last year
writing a about how
your your connection with your body it's
uh and i urge listeners to uh to to read
it um but it's it's absolutely integral
to to to what you do well i mean i was
obviously like looking at the soldier's
body was such a starting point and that
became such an important work for me um
but then through that i also got invited
to become um artist in residence at the
university of oxford to the school of
anthropology so i have actually even
properly gone and read my foucault and
my embodied theory
you know i've written papers um about
the lived experience and and how we can
use dance and use bodies to illuminate
medical conditions such as anorexia
i've worked with neuroscientists i've
looked at the connection between dance
the brain the body you know i've i've
written papers on this you know the the
body and the connection with the mind
and and how we perceive ourselves that's
that's
been fundamental to my work you know
before embodiment became something else
you know
well can you take us back to this
controversy then with with if you don't
mind what happened with this troop and
how that conversation at your dinner
party ended up
not long after you having to resign from
your own company well it i'm gonna do it
quite briefly and in a nutshell um it
got into quite an actual key to debate
about the difference between sex and
gender
and um i was explicitly asked to give my
beliefs and
um i i think you know i just have
concerns that are quite mainstream if we
erase the word woman to include anybody
that can say they're a woman or
self-identifies woman then we do lose
some of the sex-based protections and i
think like by looking at the extremes of
where that takes us
um that can tell us something about why
those sex-based protections there in the
first place
but but my a lot of my words were
misconstrued misunderstood i don't think
people really listened i think they were
quite shocked that i just didn't agree
with their orthodoxy i was very shocked
that that they had such a strong
ideology really shocked um and the more
i tried to appeal to like
my own
lived experience the worse it got the
worse it got so so i was in like proper
shock afterwards like real
shock because i'd sort of had
not not all of them but a lot of them
just shouting at me and i and i was
really it's like your worst nightmare as
a choreographer because you're relying
on these people their bodies and their
minds
to to play along with you to to put this
thing on stage that's a creation from
your imagination so if you lose them
it's a bit like sort of losing your
soldiers you know they're going to shoot
you in the head
um so i appealed to my i i really felt
paralyzed really paralyzed by the whole
thing so i appealed to my chair
um who i trusted
and i thought she would help sort it out
but very very quickly
it dawned on me that
she'd actually already taken their side
and
so we got through the show
and then i had a so-called informal
meeting and then i was told that i'd be
um investigated
um so i said okay i've never had a
complaint in all my years um
i understand there's a process let's go
through it so we did that
it it it
i had a meeting at the end i was
exonerated um i decided to
put an apology to the dancers uh for the
fact that they were so upset by what i
said
um and then we went straight back into
rehearsals again for another sort of run
of shows
one of the dancers appealed walked out
and then about three weeks later i
discovered that they were doing a second
investigation but this time
and only through accident i found out
that they were using external lawyers
an hr consultant related to the lawyers
and that these lawyers were also the
same firm as one of my trustees
um so i started to push back a bit
harder saying well hang on what what's
this secondary investigation
they refused me any support on legal
advice while they were using the company
money
to pay for lawyers to investigate me
there was no mutual investor rosie k
productions company money yeah no less
yeah yeah money that i i'd earned
through my work they were using that
money to investigate me
and then things just um got to a real
head i i found out some some some nasty
stuff some horrifically false
allegations
and i could see that this investigation
was was was that has been so
traumatizing i mean it i
you say with the first set you you
humbled yourself to apologize for
offending and yet they came back but
then
you say that you sort of
stick up for yourself you stood up for
yourself a bit more the second time
around or did you have a chair
emotionally this is one of the things i
don't think people appreciate so much
and
maybe trying to get yeah is that is the
the experience of of quote-unquote being
cancelled yeah it's it's actually very
emotional particularly for people in the
creative industries who are more
sensitive by nature and who aren't used
to being thrown into the political fray
into having people challenge them or or
uh being disliked yeah it's not about me
so i imagine not only was the experience
traumatic traumatizing of few but this
was your baby that you you know for 17
years you've built up this is you're
you've poured your life into into this
it must be very painful yeah yeah
it was it was awful and i thought i was
i actually genuinely thought i was going
mad i actually thought i was going mad
and and i was really lucky to get a
decent doctor and then
it's quite quite funny i got sent to a
psychiatrist which is saying something
you know in the on the nhs right now
and um
i went there and i had two hours talking
to this um really amazing psychiatrist
and i was really trying to convince her
that i was completely mad i was like but
you don't understand i make stuff up
that's my job you know i have these
dreams and these visions i'm clearly
something so like wrong with me and and
she asked me to explain this party in
this argument a couple of times and then
she you know she got to the end and i
thought come on i'm mad and she just she
said no there's nothing wrong with you
there's nothing wrong with you i could
give you any drug you want i don't think
you want any drugs but basically you're
very very stressed you're having a
terrible time at work and you might need
to think about your future for your own
health is there anything in in that in
that experience with all these people
accusing you of such thing that you're
like oh maybe they're right it was if
maybe i am doing something wrong when
you say you convince yourself you're mad
is that because so many people were
gaslighting you that you started to
gaslight yourself and and and you know i
am
you know i'm in the middle of creating a
romeo and juliet that's about murder and
knife crime and suicide and i'm like
completely raw and open and then this
attack comes into like this vacuum i'm
still recovering from my my dad's death
and and
all i just felt was this overwhelming
terrible
sense of like doom it was just
[Music]
um and actually it was my closest family
my mom and my my husband to
actually my husband just said no you're
not mad no no no good for him yeah
they they bullied you yeah and looking
back now
yeah it was like it was like a kind of
it was a witch hunt it really was and
that now i'm trying to like figure out
the meaning of these things the meaning
of which hunts them why why do these
pylons happen why they're happening now
what's going on this is absolutely
fascinating to me
but
but i suppose
i i
you you do go into quite a severe
you know profound existential
soul-searching
because you really have to go why am i
doing what i do
why why why are my beliefs and my
thoughts about reality
so offensive to other people
well hang on do i still stand by them
yes i do
well then
i have to get through this you know i
have to like um
i sort of found an inner metal that i'd
never i'd never known i knew i was
strong because yeah i'm a dancer it's
hard
um but i didn't know quite that my soul
was so so tough as well one never expect
anticipates that one would have to go
through an experience like this it's not
something we were taught about in school
necessarily about these sort of uh
phenomena are going to happen and it is
a phenomenon of of the age
in that sense but funnily enough
actually i i come from um so my grandad
was a post-refugee and fled uh the nazis
and joined the polish-free army um and
married a scottish woman and a lot of my
family were exterminated um in poland
and then
my first job as a dancer professional
dancer was in poland in the late 90s
so
not only did i grow up with ideas around
um you know
what happened to i love germany it's the
most wonderful country i love all the
literature the music the arts
what happened then i sort of was always
quite obsessed by
the rise of fascism
um and and also then the communist sort
of
iron curtain that came down over poland
and then sort of thwarted polish arts
so
i grew up with you know these debates at
the dinner table talking about freedom
freedom of speech i investigated by my
artists people like otto dix and this
kind of shock from world war one but
then also did they capitulate or did
they flee germany in the in the thirties
and then i also studied um
weimar republic choreographers
and and people like mary wigman and
rudolph lauben have quite ambiguous
relationships to what happened with the
state in the 30s in germany
um
and so then living in poland uh in the
90s it was post-communist but it wasn't
in the eu yet
it it reminded actually it reminded me
being in a post-dance theater was a
little bit like the company of romeo and
juliet
it was a little bit paranoid you had to
be careful what you said
it was quite competitive
um
but my friends were all theatre
practitioners and artists
and what polish artists had learnt to do
under communism was make their work
deeply and vastly symbolic
so they never said anything pro against
the state
but you had these incredible imagery and
they would play with imagery but nothing
would ever be fixed it would morph into
something else and i've always loved
that about my job at dance it's like you
can put one stereotype there but you
minute you see it you can morph it and
undermine whatever you're thinking in
your head
and so playing with symbolism playing
with power playing with reality i i
think there's something interesting
there so this is an interesting time to
be an artist
oh yeah absolutely well what do you
think what what do you think's behind
the the uh the the ideology of of let's
say this troop that you you you faced
that you were up against what do you
think's driving that and what's the
what's the the what is the world of of
dance where where is this coming from
because is it a generational thing is it
all of dance i found in the music
industry for example that
it is majority progressive yep
in terms of politics but um that also uh
the kind of artists aged between 15 and
25 have quite a lot of power because
they're the ones who sell the most
records and so whatever they believe
does sort of dictate
a lot of what the other you know
what what can and can't be said amongst
other people within the industry
by comparison with with in dance and
what does that world look like
well i i hadn't realized that there was
this ideological capture going on and
and it wasn't it hasn't been that long
since i was involved in in universities
and lecturing in academia
i was probably there just before things
kind of really like i was saying about
being in the school of anthropology
there certainly was no pronouns or
anything coming in at that point but
there were definitely sort of arguments
you know of course being anthropology as
well there were big arguments about its
colonial history and and history of
racism which i found fascinating
and about time so this is the thing this
i think for lots of us that are possibly
this sort of like sandwich generation um
there's an element of truth in in in
lots of these things a lot of these
progressive political ideas like um you
know feminists were always about
destroying the gender stereotypes and i
you know women can do anything that men
can do make anything women can do
oh hang on but that doesn't mean that
men are women or women and men you know
oh hang on there are some sort of
biological realities which which which
play a part in why women are an
oppressed majority
um you know and then there's been this
stuff around around racism around
history and colonialization you know
there's elements of truth to all of that
and and you can kind of go yeah well i
agree i agree to a certain point
i i don't quite know why it's gone so
massive and so widespread i mean there's
there's different theories around that
and and one can sort of trace it back to
probably the 1960s or
certainly sort of the late 90s and sort
of
queer theory and critical race theory
and things that seem to be on the fringe
of becoming mainstream
how does that get into dance are these
are these uh
kids who are studying uh dance after
school
wherever they are university are they
being taught that stuff there or is it
just in the water for them
in their lives
is it is it is it is the sort of
fukovian
uh
philosophy that you you've studied
somehow
actually penetrated into the world of
dance
and not and not just in the the ideas
that are commonplace but rather that
they're being taught
i think a couple of things happened and
there's a conclusion of what's going on
particularly in the arts at the moment
in the conservatoires um
obviously when people started like
having to pay their own fees and
students started being called clients or
customers rather than students and so
the power of those students and the
retention became all pervasive and then
you have this kind of like you have this
grievance culture this complaint culture
this anonymous can claim its culture now
when i was at dan school i would say it
was too far the other way and it was it
was tough it was really tough i you know
i definitely wouldn't want to go back to
that way of teaching however there's two
tough things in what sense of
authoritarian teacher very authoritarian
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah there's a wrong
and a right and that's it that's final
um you know
now it's probably gone a bit too far the
other way in that there's a rejection of
any kind of level of authority or or
also there's like this sort of wider
rejection of experts or expertise
and and there's a lot to do about
people's feelings and emotions and
there's very little kind of like
knowledge based
sort of study that you can only have i
mean i don't really care too much about
these emotions and feelings you need to
fill yourself with as much knowledge as
possible yeah um
what was interesting about romeo and
juliet was actually the dancers that
came through different training strands
so either through hip-hop or through
south asian dance like barinating or
qatar
they didn't have these beliefs
um it was the dancers that had gone
through the conservatoires
so i do think there's something about um
you know luxury beliefs luxury belief
systems that that
that people
hang on to
there's definitely a sort of culture of
who's the most oppressed
um
and i just don't really have any i'm not
really interested in that i mean i mean
i've worked with really difficult
inner-city schools and students and the
arts are brilliant at like you know
expanding people's worlds i'm not gonna
i wanna i wanna do that kind of work not
sit down and and naval gaze ourselves
that's not what the arts are for
i also think
there's a real lack of
good teaching about what the arts really
are for like the deep meaning of what
arts actually do in society we are here
to shock we are we are here to like peel
back the eyelids of people and take a
society out of inertia and out of
complacency that's what we're here to do
absolutely and you look at the best art
that changed the world like there's uh
sacred
uh by nizinski or or um even you know
the mark was the sad or you know other
shocking people the young british
artists of the 90s it shocked us all and
it shifts society yeah being told to
shut up
you're not allowed to speak or you or
we're going to keep you under control
where you're never allowed to speak
again that's impossible for me it's just
impossible i wasn't going to do it so
that's about that's why i resigned it's
you've resigned and you're now as i said
earlier relaunching or launching k2 co
yes is that is that uh rosie k 2.0
company
if i understood that right well it's the
k is important because um my
grandfather's real name was kriet koski
and kviet is flower and polish but it
gives that a k and there was quite a lot
of anti-polish feeling when my
grandfather and grandmother had to stay
in scotland they wanted to go back to
poland but they couldn't
um so the letter a family name became k
um and
so the k is important yes it's my second
company and um it's it's a it's a new
start it's a fresh start and
what was what was lovely and and
shocking to me in january after i'd sort
of recovered a bit like you say it's
just hugely um like physically takes so
much out of you i hadn't eaten
for weeks i was sort of shaking and
vomiting it was awful
um
once i recovered and slept
i just had this explosion of like the
new work i wanted to make and just being
really brave and going like i'm gonna
focus on women on sex on gender i'm
gonna go for it and i wrote this trilogy
of works
and felt really happy about it and then
slowly slowly just started talking to
theaters directors programmers
saying you're still interested in my
work and people are so oh great
so what will the first work be will it
be orlando well so so i'm gonna tour
five soldiers next year because i think
that's just a really good piece that
sort of for anyone who hasn't seen my
work live it it gives you a taste of you
know what what it is i do
um
the first part of the trilogy is going
to be called um deep fake and i'm
looking at bodies a woman's body
identity what happens if your actual
physical body becomes obsolete and your
digital self is more important deep
vague stuff is so spooky it's absolutely
terrifying
i hope we haven't experienced any
fortunately not no no but it really like
that
i've worked with like cyber experts and
um you can now fake people's voices like
you you could get your mom calling you
up saying i've been kidnapped i need
ransom and it's utterly convincing it's
your mum's voice this is post-post-truth
world we're in
exactly so you've written what the part
one of your trilogy is is deep fake and
so i'm busy in the studio experimenting
with that and trying to find like this
kind of new really weird slightly poppy
odd language disembodied language yeah
um i made a piece called mk ultra about
brainwashing
uh when would that be about like
five six years ago and so this feels
like they want the next one it's like
like you say like when i was talking
about conspiracy everyone was saying oh
you're bonkers we're way past conspiracy
now like reality's conspiracy it's just
yeah weird
so that's the first part and then the
second part would be orlando and i think
that's like super theatrical
really over the top
i think really funny i mean really funny
a comedy probably great well i'm i'm
very excited i'll be there
to i've seen them and i hope that um
your story gives sucker to
uh many other people who feel like they
have to self-censor and feel like they
can't um you know express themselves uh
truly and and um perhaps your new
company will be a home for for them and
and other people in the dance world to
come to well i hope so so
um that that's one of the things i've
been working on with my my new advisory
board is is we're gonna put together a
charter of creation and and it's really
like you don't have to sign it it's not
a policy it's not employment policy but
it's something that just says this is a
place
where you're safe to speak to think to
challenge ideas no one will be silenced
nobody be cancelled we're here to work
together for the purpose of art we're
here to understand what the purpose of
art is and let the audience be our judge
you know you make the work and let the
people judge you let's not judge
ourselves before we've made the art
because we're not going to make anything
else a freedom of expression charter
yeah yeah exactly and you know i've
thought a lot about this because because
you you hear these things old freedom of
speech is a cover for the right wing or
something like this but actually i trace
it right back to freedom of thought
freedom of conscience yeah you know
people died for this for freedom of
conscience
then you have once you've gone through
the thought process and your conscience
then you have the the area of expression
which is the arts and for me you know
that's that's done so i'm not speaking
but then actually here we are
and speech is vitally important
because to be silenced and to be
terrified and be scared to have your
livelihood threatened so much
we're on the cusp of something i don't
think it's inevitable
that it carries on down this route it's
not inevitable i see a lot of hope
however
it is a dangerous moment
and so
i wouldn't you know it's certainly not
nice what happened to me it's awful i'm
not going to deny that but also i would
want to say to other people do what you
can in your own way to speak out and to
resist yeah um it can be tiny or it can
be big um
but we we need to have a pluralistic
society and a tolerant society and
that's what i love about you know
so much of the western canon is is based
on that explosion of ideas and the
testing of ideas yeah well rotate that
is absolutely the world i want to live
in so more power to you and
i very much look forward to watching uh
your new company blossom bloom grow and
um it's gonna be great i'm sure so
congratulations
[Music]
you